today on the matt walsh show aoc is
still talking about the supposed trauma
she experienced on january 6th even
though she was never in any danger and
never personally encountered any rioters
at all we'll discuss also five headlines
including the media finally coming
around to the idea that kovid came from
a chinese lab after a year of insisting
that this was all a conspiracy theory
funny how things change also the white
house finally acknowledges the surge in
violent crime in our cities but pins the
whole issue on lacks gun control of
course and students at a school in new
york were given a class on pornography
without parental consent in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the push
to normalize facial hair on women
yeah that's a thing now it is a thing
and we'll talk about it all of that and
much more today on the matte wall show
[Music]
now a word from new sponsors on the show
that we're very excited about ar 500
armor you know so this is something that
i have myself
taken more seriously especially in in
recent times
um this uh
the the fact that i have a
responsibility to be able to protect
myself and my family
you've heard me share about how
important this second amendment is to
the foundation of our country and you
might be one of the over 5 million
citizens who purchased a firearm for the
first time in 2020 and maybe you're
beginning to take this more seriously as
well if you're taking the first step of
protecting yourself with a firearm the
next step in your personal protection
plan should be considering body armor
for yourself and your family shopping
for body armor may seem like something
you never thought you'd have to do you
may not know where to begin in fact you
may not even know maybe maybe you didn't
even know you could buy body armor well
you can that's where ar 500 armor comes
in ar ar 500 armor
dot com makes buying body armor easy
approachable and affordable in fact with
ar 500 armor dot com you buy it online
you have it shipped straight to your
house ar 500 armor has multiple packages
built for people just like you who are
looking for varying levels of protection
and best of all they've put together
some packages specifically for listeners
of the daily wires so there's something
for everyone at ar500armor.com
go to
ar500armor.comwalsh to see all their
promotions and special pricing running
right now and you can use code walsh for
20 off anything else in their entire
store
uh plan right now for how to protect
yourself and your family for the future
get yourself the body armor we trust
from ar 500 armor at ahar 500 armor dot
com slash walsh visit ar 500 armor dot
com slash walsh and use code wall should
check out for 20 off
so nearly five months after the events
of january 6 the one solitary example of
right-wingers participating in a riot
after months and years of near non-stop
left-wing rides nearly five months later
many of our lawmakers
none of whom were physically harmed in
the incident have not been able to
emotionally recover and they're always
eager to remind us of that fact none so
eager as alexandria queso cortez who
appeared on a podcast called latino usa
a few days ago to once again
discuss her trauma now personally i'm
traumatized that the show is called
latino usa and not the more inclusive le
tinx usa but for whatever reason aoc
chose to appear on this bigoted
transphobic show during the course of
the conversation she repeatedly claimed
that what happened on january 6th was an
attempted coup
and that it was
mere seconds away from being successful
she also complained of her own emotional
and psychological trauma and said that
she has been in therapy because of it
let's uh listen to a little bit of that
i think after the sixth i took some time
and
it was really ayanna presley when i
explained to her what had happened to me
like the day of because i ran to her
office
and she was like you need to recognize
trauma
and that this is something that
you went through but we're all going
through
and um and it's really important to
pause after that
because that's how you process it
and
i feel like i learned this the hard way
after my father had passed away when i
was a teenager because i was like you
know first born
only daughter of a latina family you
know how that dynamic is and
you need to like do everything
so that happened at a young age and i
socked it away
and i i had to live with that for years
and so
i learned my lesson then and now i feel
like i've kind of taken i've had to take
a beat
if i take a couple months now
and just be really good then i don't
have to live
with this thing festering and lingering
with me like a roommate in my apartment
for years
so you're doing therapy yeah oh yeah i
i'm doing therapy but also
i've just slowed down
i think the trump administration had a
lot of us especially latino communities
in a very reactive mode
and so i've
been
putting myself in more proactive space
there was a time when people would be
embarrassed
to admit that they're in therapy and
that was that was wrong because it's not
it's not shameful in and of itself to be
in therapy but we have we've massively
over corrected to the to the other side
to the other uh end of the extreme and
you can be sure that you know that your
trauma is especially severe
when someone has to tell you that you're
suffering it
you know now you mention it i am
traumatized that's how you know you have
the real stuff right that's how we think
of trauma now we think of
something that you might not even
know about uh so you need someone to
tell you whether it's a therapist or a
friend to tell you that you're
traumatized and that's how you know
i think with with real trauma is that no
one needs to tell you i mean it's
possible to really be traumatized by
traumatizing things experiences
you don't need anyone to tell you that
that's how you feel
because it's it's abundantly clear
now before we talk more about the
alleged trauma it i think it must be
clarified once again
and we have to keep clarifying it that
uh what happened on january 6
6 was not a not a coup okay it was not a
near coup
it was not an attempted coup
it was not an almost coup wasn't even
coup adjacent
a coup
is when a group of people usually a
small group
violently overthrow the government
that's what a coup is
the people in the capitol building that
day they were not going to overthrow the
government
they were not close to overthrowing the
government there was no threat that they
would overthrow the government
overthrowing the government
was not on the menu of plausible
outcomes that day it was just not going
to
happen you know what happened it could
have gone
like any event it could have gone many
different ways
but it could have gone that way the
government was not getting overthrown
and it wasn't what they were trying to
do anyway
if you actually think that our
government can be overthrown overturned
in a matter of a few hours by a bunch of
hooligans taking selfies and stealing
furniture then uh you know i don't know
what to tell you
january 6 what what was it it qualifies
as a riot
and not everybody
um who was there in dc that day was
involved in a riot
but uh but some were
and it qualifies as trespassing
and it qualifies as vandalism in some
cases but it was not a serious and
organized attempt to actually overthrow
and take over the government which means
that it was not a coup
and it was not an insurrection
and as has been pointed out many times
and we must continue pointing out if it
was a coup in an in an insurrection then
that label
certainly applies to every single blm
riot that we've seen over the last
many years in fact
now as for the trauma i think the
assumption among many people on the
right
is that people like aoc
and all the other democrats who've made
similar claims are simply lying about
their trauma they're pretending to have
been emotionally scarred this is all one
big fraudulent sob story and the
evidence marshaled by those who take
this position includes the fact that
many americans across the country
endured as we just discussed weeks of
sustained violent writing and neither
aoc nor any other democrat ever asked
them about their trauma or showed any
concern for it whatsoever
aoc wasn't even in the building when the
riot happened or where it happened
she at no point actually encountered the
riots at all she was in no danger
whatsoever what about store owners
who had to run out and seek cover while
their shops were being looted and burned
many such cases
you know it it seems as if if aoc had
trauma then they had something much
worse than trauma
yet aoc and the other democrats has no
evident concern for them far from it in
fact they defend and romanticize the
rioting in that case
so all of that is true
um it's also true that aoc has a history
of pretending to be upset and
traumatized but i think she has a
history of shedding crocodile tears like
when she pretended to cry in front of an
empty parking lot a few years ago
infamous infamously
but even with all that said
i don't think these people are
necessarily
lying about feeling traumatized
we should not underestimate
or overlook the fact that washington dc
is currently full of some of the weakest
and most fragile human beings on earth
these are not leaders
that's a big part of our problem right
now politically in this country
and not just people who are weak and
fragile
but who are in fact proud
to be so
that's why aoc is talking openly about
needing therapy for this
if you do need therapy for that's not
something i'd be bragging about
if aoc though says that she's in she's
nearly incapacitated she's in a state of
shock
still like trembling in fear because
some people were trespassing in a
building across the way from her five
months ago
i think we should take her out of word
we we live in a culture overrun by
people who are not able to process
uncomfortable feelings or difficult
situations people who run to therapy or
reach for prescription drugs rather than
simply endure even the mildest
difficulties
and in fact when you think about it it
only makes sense that we should be led
by those kinds of people as well
now let's get to our five headlines
now check it in with uh another new
sponsor on the show we're excited about
true bill now you know two problems that
plague i think modern people many
problems but here are two one is that
you you have you have a million
different passwords for a million
different things you can never remember
them and the other is you you probably
signed up for a bunch of subscriptions
and you can't even remember which ones
and uh and and all of that true bill is
the smartest way to manage your finances
and deal with this problem at least when
it comes to the subscriptions it's an
easy to use app you can review your
recurring charges in one place cancel
subscriptions directly through the app
because sometimes you know you have
you're signed up for a subscription you
forget that you're signed up for it and
then you're paying for it not using it
that's uh that happens to people all the
time i know it's happened to me truebill
has a variety of tools to help customers
improve their finances you can create a
monthly budget and expenses you can
track and evaluate savings goals
you can work with many of the nation's
top providers to negotiate and lower
your bills people think they spend
around 80 bucks a month on subscriptions
but actually spend closer to 200 bucks a
month and that's a big difference
the average person saves 720 per year
with true bill those are big savings get
started today then at truebill.com matt
take control of your finances and start
saving at truebill.com that's
truebill.com
matt
uh i i just i wanted to mention
not not really a headline but i don't
know if you knew that yesterday was uh
hopefully you did know you you
celebrated um
that yesterday was pan
visibility day
actually i'm sorry it's uh pansexual and
pan-romantic awareness and visibility
day so you got to be aware of them and
also make sure that they're visible
um now
the the one
thing the one immediate problem that
comes up when you think about trying to
make pansexual people more visible is
that
they don't exist
you know because that's not a thing
and so that's a problem when you want to
be aware of people and you want them to
be visible but they don't exist it's a
little bit of a difficulty or or you
know it could go i there's one of two
ways
um
nobody is pansexual or maybe everybody
is because it depends on on how you
define it
so i did look this up because i wanted
to participate in uh pansexual awareness
and visibility day i care deep as you
know
uh i care deeply about these kinds of
things
and
so i looked it up there's a in fact
twitter linked to this it's
a website called gendered intelligence
understanding gender diversity and in
creative ways this is a website out of
the uk
and
here's what they say
they say on pan visibility day we want
to debunk the misconceptions that still
exist about being pansexual and
pan-romantic
bad representation visibility are
crucial for recognition and ultimately
for lgbtq plus equality
uh okay
so what is it that's the question we all
have first things first it's a real
identity and not a rare one pansexuality
is still regarded as an identity by as a
disregarded as an identity by many but
more and more people are coming out as
pansexual including celebrities and mps
like leila morin
okay a fun fact about the word pan is
the greek word for all
pansexuality doesn't mean liking or
loving everyone you meet
just because pansexual people can feel
attracted to people regardless of their
gender it doesn't mean they'll feel
attracted or in love with everyone they
meet
um
okay so
this is just bisexual i guess well no it
says pansexuality is not the same as
bisexuality but they can co-exist
bisexuality means being attracted to
more than one gender so many bisexual
people also identify as pansexual and
vice versa
what being bisexual and pansexual means
is ultimately down to each individual
definitions are there to guide us but
they're not ultimate truths
everyone has their own interpretation of
what an identity means and that's
totally okay so this was a
this is a reference guide that i think
twitter linked to and twitter would
never steer us wrong
and this is supposed to tell us what pan
sexual people are on pan visibility day
and awareness day
and uh there are a whole bunch of words
no definition it's not anything
kind of beats around the bush a little
bit and then when we get down to the
brass tacks it tells us that well you
know definitions what's a definition
anyway
it's whatever you want it to be
so
go back to the beginning either there
are no pansexuals or maybe everybody is
because it could be anything
maybe i'm a pansexual
it's possible
um all right
let's go here number one former
secretary of state mike pompeo might
also be pansexual for all we know
he was on fox yesterday he says that
he's convinced
that
kovid came from a chinese lab but what
you're about to hear
if this was
a month ago and any time before that uh
this would be condemned as conspiracy
mongering and so on but now all of a
sudden this is a this is an acceptable
theory let's listen to him
and so there are many things the united
states government could do to impose
real costs on the chinese communist
party until they come clean about what
they know and what they did we know for
sure they covered up this virus i am
confident that we will find that the
evidence that we have seen to date is
consistent with a lab leak and i'm
convinced that's what we'll see if i'm
wrong i hope the chinese communist party
will come forward and make a fool of if
only we had if this is the true
and this happened november of 2019
if only the world would have known think
about how much grief this planet would
have been spared
oh bill i remember talking with dr
redfield about this at great length we
were working so hard hhs secretary azar
myself we were working so hard to get
this information this would have been
early january of 2020 when we were still
trying to figure out precisely what was
about to hit the world and the chinese
communist party had gone completely dark
they wouldn't take our phone calls they
wouldn't answer our questions we sent
inquiries
we couldn't get a straight answer our
ambassador
ambassador branstad couldn't get a
straight answer the chinese communist
party clearly knew they had a problem
they didn't want the world to know it
and i'm convinced they still know they
have a problem and don't want us to know
it
yeah this is uh i i
was saying months ago at the very
beginning this to me seems
uh
this has shades of chernobyl it seems a
lot like
chernobyl a lot of ways and that's
assuming that uh
the virus
leaked from a lab intentionally and
there was no purpose behind it i think
that's another thing we don't we just
don't know
but
this is
kind of like chernobyl but a lot worse
in terms of the death toll and
the the global implications
but this is something that you're
allowed to say now
now you're allowed to say it
but as you recall for months and months
um this was this was a conspiracy theory
and i think there's there are a couple
things going on here
for why
you know the media's changed course on
this
partly they've changed course because
they have no
choice
the evidence more and more is pointing
and that the evidence is always pointed
in that direction
um
but what we know from the media is they
don't
they don't want you drawing conclusions
before they tell you to draw them
a lot of this is about power and control
i think the assumption from a lot of
people on the right is the the media is
trying to cover for the communist
chinese government i'm sure there's some
of that
but i think there's also just your
standard ordinary narcissism
among these uh people in the media
where where they say no no no you you
wait for us we'll tell you
we along with certain people in
government and the so-called experts
will we will tell you when you're
allowed to believe xyz
that's up for uh to us to decide
what we've seen with covet over the last
year and this this of course predates
covid
but um
especially over the last year there's
been this just all-out attack on common
sense
where you're not allowed to make common
sense judgments
and you didn't have to be an expert you
didn't have to be in the intelligence
community
to
a year ago
look at the situation and say huh
this came from wuhan they've got this
um lab right there in wuhan
what are the chances
what are the chances that
coincidentally with no connection
you've got this global pandemic this
virus that originates in an area of the
world where they've also got this lab
there
there's a chance that it's coincidental
but from the beginning it seemed like
most most likely this is uh there's a
lot of smoke there's probably fire
situation
when choosing between
you know when you have two options and
one is a wild
incredible coincidence
and the other is where you where there
are a couple of dots that are easily
connected and you connect them
and if you have no other information
it doesn't make any sense to assume that
the coincidence is is is the explanation
and certainly at least
it's worth talking about
but these are that's a common sense
conclusion just like the people
from the very beginning who said
it
why you know why are we telling people
they can't walk around outside why are
we shutting down parks and playgrounds
why are we shutting down
um
beaches
why are people wearing masks when
they're walking around outside this
doesn't make any sense it's it's there's
there's no comments use your common
sense this is this we shouldn't be doing
this
but that's another one where yet now the
so-called experts in the media they've
gone on board with that a year later
after screaming at us that if we made
that argument up until now we were
trying to kill everyone's grandmothers
um so i think that's a lot of what this
is it's an attack on common sense and
part of the reason why there's this
attack on common sense happening on the
part of the media is that they
want you to wait for them
so that they have that control and power
because they're more intelligent than
you and me
and they'll tell us when we're allowed
to think
anything really
all right number two from the daily wire
says parents of students attending
columbia grammar and preparatory school
in manhattan were furious after the
school forced students to take an
explicit class on pornography
without parental consent of course the
school at first denied hosting the
workshop then later apologized the class
which involved the slideshow and a
lecture by an instructor
featured raunchy images and
presentations on porn genres and only
fans
subscription website used largely for
pornography the new york post detailed
the workshop
let's see how much of this i can
actually read
the often explicit slide presentation
lecture by
the person's name is
fonte justine ang fonte is the lecture
the presentation lecture by fonte to the
120 boys and girls included lessons on
how porn takes care of three big male
vulnerability vulnerabilities
statistics on the orgasm gap showing
straight women have far fewer orgasms
with their partners than gay men or
women and photos of partially nude women
summon bondage bondage to analyze what
is porn and what is art
fonte's presentation some of which was
seen by the post included a list of the
most searched pornographic terms of 2019
including and now there are a bunch of
things that i know i can't read on the
air um
one slide cited various porn genres such
as incest themed
consensual
barely legal
and kink and bdsm
the workshop was designed and taught by
justine fonte the health director at
dalton another top prep school
and by the way i looked up her bio
um
and her bio says that she's on twitter
anyway says she's a passionate she they
health educator fighting for a more sex
sex-positive world
uh so that's what's happening at that
school i mean this is this is a slightly
more grotesque and explicit version
of the kind of sex sex ed that you find
in schools all across the country so you
might say well yeah this is some
fancy school in new york
a bunch of far left wackos are there
mostly far left wackos sending their
kids there of course this is happening
there
it's not happening in my kid's school
they would never do that
i wouldn't be so sure
this is
again slightly more explicit
than if your kid is
16 years old and is in a public school
they've probably had a lesson similar to
this maybe slightly more toned down
because that's what that's what sex ed
is that's the whole point
that's the whole point of sex ed in
school now
what they call uh comprehensive sex
education
that's the term of art for it so if your
kid's been through a comprehensive sex
education course they've been through
stuff like this
which is why i have always said that
and this should have been our argument
all along it should have been
uh let's reform sex ed or let's make
sure there's parental consent before or
any of that
our argument all along should have been
this shouldn't none of this should be in
be taught in school at all yes there
should be no sex ed in school at all
nothing called sex ed
we want to teach about
human reproduction
great that's for science we want to talk
about the the the body parts and how
they function
fantastic well there's there are classes
for that anatomy you know that's anatomy
that's biology
so
i'm not saying that the school should
overlook
the scientific facts of human
reproduction entirely no
although we're getting to a point now
where i don't trust the school to teach
those subjects either because who knows
what they're telling kids about how do
you determine a male from a female and
that kind of thing
but in an ideal scenario yeah obviously
you're going to teach that stuff in
school because these are scientific
facts
but there's no reason why the school
should
go beyond that at all we don't need to
get into any of uh you know you're
trying to shape
how kids view sexuality
giving them advice
on how to engage in it when to engage in
it none of that
your own your own per as a teacher your
own personal moral and ethical views on
these subjects none of that should be in
the school
it's not the place for
that it have been our message all along
on the right but but it wasn't and so
now you end up with this kind of thing
the other thing you have to keep in mind
is that
you know the schools believe
that they have total control over your
kids
and that they are more you know that
that their moral claim to your children
supersedes your own
because they're the educators
and you're sending your kid to them for
six or seven hours a day
and so they they really believe
most of the people running these schools
across the country
they really believe that as a parent
it's it's actually none of your business
what's happening at school
if your kid
comes out as transgender at school and
all the teachers know it
it's none of your business they don't
have to tell you that
that's that's the attitude and um
so when you send your kid into school
that's
what you're encountering that's what
they're encountering i should say
all right number three from the daily
mail says joe biden uh will skip a
commencement ceremony traditionally
attended by presidents amid a row over
his pro-abortion views of the catholic
university biden's administration will
be the first since bill clinton's to
skip the university of notre dame's
commencement ceremony after more than 4
000 students and alumni signed a
petition urging school officials not to
invite the president over his pro-choice
view on abortion uh white house official
told the catholic news agency on may 11
that the president was invited to give a
commencement speech and receive an honor
honorary degree from the school but
would not attend due to a scheduling
conflict so they're saying it's a
scheduling conflict but really you know
they don't want to send joe biden in to
give this commencement address and then
it's a protest or something and so
that's why they're not doing it to save
him the embarrassment uh this is a this
is a rare encouraging story so i'm glad
we put it in here
it's not so much encouraging on the part
of school that they invited him to speak
in the first place this is what we
expect from notre dame the people
running that school it's been that way
for a long time but at least the
students
and some faculty members
did the right thing and said no you
can't send
he he doesn't but this is this is
supposed to be a catholic university
we can't have him here speaking
especially because he claims to be a
catholic now i think
for if memory serves me and based on
this article obama spoke
at a commencement at notre dame
even though he obviously
is far left pro-abortion
and that was horrible and never should
have happened but that
wouldn't be as bad as joe biden speaking
because at least obama doesn't claim to
be a catholic
and so there's no confusion there
but there's a real there's a real
scandal when you've got these
politicians who claim to be catholic but
clearly aren't and then they're given
platforms by catholic institutions
that's a real scandal that's a real
problem
and yes i can say that i can say that
joe biden is not catholic no matter what
he says
i'm in a position where i can declare
not because i have any special authority
but simply because being catholic means
something
and and
anyone who is catholic we have to insist
that it means something
now on the left they can make up labels
and identities that mean nothing
pansexual can mean means everything
means nothing fine
being a catholic means something
and one of the most fundamental things
that it means is that you accept the
moral authority of the church if you
don't accept the moral authority of the
church
you don't have to there's no law saying
you have to in this country
and if you don't okay but then you're
not a catholic obviously
if you think of the the catholic church
as just you know just just a a human
institution like any other
um prone to make moral errors and so on
then then okay but clearly you're not a
catholic
and that's what joe biden believes even
if he doesn't say it
that's obviously what he believes
because he thinks that the catholic
church got it wrong
on this central moral issue
and not just this one but many others
uh more news from the white house jen
saki was asked about uh the the rise in
violent crime and
she
acknowledged it for a change but here's
what she pins it on let's listen
4 000 more people shot
and killed by guns at 2020 compared to
the year before is there a crime problem
in this country
well i would say certainly there is a
guns problem
and that's something the president would
say and there are communities where
local violence and community violence is
an issue and that's one of the reasons
that we have proposed and have now are
implementing funding for community
violence prevention programs across the
country i will say
that we don't often highlight and you
just gave me the opportunity to the fact
that
between mass shootings mass shootings
that get a lot of attention that we
lower the flags there are hundreds
thousands of people who lose their lives
and that's one of the reasons the
president will continue to advocate for
the senate passing uh back universal
background checks but also advocate for
actions in states where we have seen uh
the greatest level of activism over the
past several years does covet have
anything to do with the increase in
numbers that we've seen in the last year
in terms of local community violence
it's an interesting question i'd have to
ask our team to check on that i know as
i started off this briefing giving an
update on that we've seen statistics on
domestic violence and obviously we know
that there are uh
the loss of life at the hands of gun
violence is often
too often suicide
can be domestic violence and we've seen
statistics as it relates to the impact
on mental health but i'd have to check
with experts on the assessment of that
okay so i guess i should correct myself
because i said that she acknowledges
the uh
the crime epidemic
but
not really they're not acknowledging
that she says well not a crime but
there's a gun problem specifically
no there's a crime problem
uh our cities across the country are
beset by crime are ravaged by crime by
violent crime and non-violent crime and
all kinds of crime uh but mostly violent
crime and not all of it involves guns in
fact a lot of it doesn't
and of those that do involve guns of
course the the uh i don't think i didn't
spend much time on this because we're
probably on the same page the
the suggestion
that all you have to do is have stricter
gun laws and that's going to solve the
problem is it is it's an it's an insult
to our intelligence it's absurd
we can start with the fact that in many
of these cities
almost all of these cities are blue
um
run by democrats
and they already have strict gun laws
and that has accomplished
nothing
there's there's no evidence
that especially in these cities as you
make the gun law stricter
it makes the crime go away
if that was going to be the trend we
should see some evidence of that and we
don't
so they already have these laws
um
the average criminal in let's say
baltimore city
have you got some 18 year old gangbanger
out there or younger a lot of times
let's let's just take a you know a
hypothetical case but one that happens
many times every day in cities across
the country
um and accounts for
a big a great portion of the homicides
so you've got a um
a teenage
male
gang banger
running up and shooting someone else um
over a dispute
a drug-related dispute
trying to protect his coroner or
whatever
okay
how many crimes have been committed
in that
act because we we can already guarantee
that the gun he's using is an illegal
gun he did not he didn't go to a gun he
most likely
didn't go to a gun gun shop and fill out
the paperwork and present his id and do
all of that
he got the gun some other way
so he's already by possessing the gun
he's already committing a crime
by using the gun to shoot someone he's
committing a crime
he's involved in
in uh he's a drug dealer he's committing
a crime there like
many many crimes committed in that one
act
so
by making more laws
so let's say that he let's say that in
that one act he commits six different
crimes
okay pass more laws and instead of
commit committing six crimes he commits
ten
or twenty
doesn't matter
pass so many laws so that in that one
act of shooting the other drug dealer on
the street corner he commits 50 crimes
well commit
commit six crimes or 50 break six laws
or 50 laws what difference does it make
if the six laws didn't do it i don't
think adding a bunch more will make a
difference
especially when you're not enforcing the
laws that are already on the books
and what what do you need to enforce
laws
let me think for a second
who are those people
right now i'm blanking
who are those people that are in charge
of enforcing laws what do we call them
law enforcement that's it yeah law enfo
it's actually law enforcement officers
are the people who enforce the laws
so for the laws we have in the books
right now we need we need those people
to do that job
and if you make more laws then probably
need even more law enforcement officers
to enforce all the extra laws that we
have
but on the left they want to have
more laws
and fewer people to enforce them
you want to talk about trends okay how
does that work more so laws are they
want laws to go up like this but then
law enforcement to go down like that
there's a big gap here and that gap is a
problem
and that gap gets filled in with a lot
more violence
and a lot more crime
speaking of uh law enforcement let me i
want to
talk about this as well
because because cops were actually i
noticed this on social media cops were
receiving some praise on social media
for a change
after bringing um this happened a couple
days ago they brought a quadruple murder
suspect
they brought him in he was on the lamb
they brought him in safely no no shots
fired nobody was killed
and so that's why the cops were actually
being praised
but let's listen to this story from fox
okay it says
the days-long manhunt for quadruple
murder suspect tyler terry came to an
end in south carolina monday morning
without violence after authorities
launched a massive operation involving a
force of 300 officers to squeeze out the
suspect from his hiding place
the chester county sheriff's office said
terry was safely taken into custody near
highway 9 and highway 99 in chester
county they said no shots were fired by
any party and that neither terry nor any
of the officers were injured during his
capture law enforcement received praise
on social media following the
announcement that the manhunt ended
safely with no injuries to the suspect
or officers one user wrote exceptional
work bringing this to a peaceful end
another said great job to all thankfully
all are okay
another one said i knew they would take
him alive
uh cops don't act like that around here
way to go
terry 26 had been evading police since
running from a car wreck after a
high-speed chase last monday night in
chester county since then officers dogs
helicopters and drones had searched the
woods neighborhoods and industrial areas
for terry
the the strong perimeter of 200 officers
in place overnight grew to more than 300
by the early morning with officers from
cities county state and federal agencies
joining the manhunt according to the
chester county sheriff's office all
right
so that's the story they brought the guy
in that's great
um and they did it they did it
peacefully and there were no he wasn't
killed in the process and we should also
note that
the
suspect here tyler terry is a black man
um
and that's kind of interesting
because we're told that
all cops do when they're bringing a
black suspect in is they just murder the
guy
with with with no provocation or or they
they wait for the slightest provocation
itchy trigger figures and they're just
looking to murder him
yet here you have a black man
wanted for four murders
known to be armed and dangerous
on the lamb
and they managed to bring him in
and this is being used as an example and
even some people on the left are saying
hey why can't
if they could do that with this guy
why can't cops always do that
well let's let's look at what was
required
first of all
300 law enforcement officers
were involved in cornering this guy
and finding him
and i'm sure that had something to do
with the fact that he was taken
peacefully
that he knew he had literally nowhere to
go
so there were a whole lot of law
enforcement officers
going to find this guy
do we think maybe it would have gone
differently
he's hiding out in the woods and uh if
they sent in like
two or three officers to go apprehend
him
we think maybe it would have gone
differently
maybe he would have said to himself oh i
could definitely get away all i could do
is you know
run away from these people maybe kill
him whatever i have to do
300 is different i can't get away from
300 people
so
they brought him in safely which is
great
they said 300 officers
and and also
as far as it says no shots were fired
which means that
the suspect
didn't instigate any violence
it seems as far as we know he didn't
fight them he certainly didn't fire any
he didn't shoot at them he didn't try to
kill them he didn't he didn't
you know get in the car and drive it
right at them nothing like that
so that's how it ended safely
and what does that tell us what lesson
can we bring from that
number one you need law enforcement
officers
and sometimes you need a lot of them
and when you're dealing with a really
dangerous person you need a whole lot of
them
the more you have in that situation the
safer it's going to be for everyone
involved including the suspect
and what does that mean it means yeah we
probably shouldn't be defunding
uh
police departments we should be funding
them
a lot of these cities a lot of these
places they need more officers not fewer
than but more officers are going to make
everyone safer including the criminals
are going to be safer
and we also learn from this that
even if you're a very dangerous very bad
guy
if you don't fight the police officers
or try to kill them while they're
bringing you in
you will almost certainly survive the
encounter and you'll be brought in
safely
no matter who you are
no matter what crime you committed no
matter what your race is
it's funny how that works
so i think that to me that's the lesson
i take from this
all right let's go now to reading the
youtube comments
um
jd says matt i get that you want people
to speak up about these issues however i
think the problem for many is not having
the platform to adequately do so
considering the few that are available
will swiftly de-platform those who speak
out in opposition as a result i believe
a more effective objective is to first
create our own infrastructure so people
that are willing to challenge these
ideologies cannot be silenced if they
took down the daily wire tomorrow
then blocked you from twitter and
facebook similarly to what they did to
stephen crowder your ability to speak
out effectively would be nearly
eliminated i'm not saying i know what
the solution is but i think the days
where simply letting our voices be heard
um had any substantial power are far
gone okay so there's two quick points
here i agree
with a lot of what you're saying
but first of all
um there's there's no escaping the
responsibility that we all have to speak
up
and i'm not saying if we all speak up
that magically everything will be better
tomorrow
but you're you're referencing i think
specifically what we talked about top of
the show yesterday
the the gender ideology madness kids
that are being sucked into this thing
being mutilated and destroyed
permanently
disfigured drugged and all of that
um what i know for sure is that if the
sane decent people in this country are
silent and rem
we already are many already are silent
if they remain silent
then there's nothing that can be done
there's no hope
because there are a whole lot of people
that look at this
or many other situations they know that
it's wrong they know that it's awful
but they don't say anything because
they're afraid
and as long as that's going to continue
then there's no hope
so this that's the responsibility that
we all have as far as building
infrastructures and that sort of thing
so we're not as susceptible to being
shut down by facebook and twitter and
all that i totally agree with you there
and not to turn this into a uh
shameless promotion or advertisement but
that's one of the reasons why the daily
wire is trying to build up a subscriber
base so that we're not as
susceptible and vulnerable to facebook
just coming along and saying never mind
you don't you don't get to exist anymore
which they could do to
you know many conservative voices and
and outlets
so become become a member today
um
noah says hey matt i didn't agree with
you on the pitbull argument until today
i was at the neighbor's house and there
were a pit bull broke out of the room
ran at me and bit me for no discernible
reason
many such cases many such cases
but they're cute though right they're
cute until they're
they're uh
you know gnawing at your arm until they
rip your arm off they're very cute and
that's what matters
michelle says how is affirmative care at
all helpful what if we told
schizophrenics
we'll agree with whatever you say and
not challenge your delusions at all the
whole point of therapy is that it's
supposed to challenge delusion to root
out mental disease and hopefully
discover
a useful treatment yeah the the whole
idea of affirmative care is a is a
is an oxymoron it's it's a contradiction
in terms it's a non-sequitur doesn't
make any sense
uh if someone's coming in and they're
plagued by a delusion of any kind you're
as a therapist if you have any role at
all if you're gonna you're gonna be
useful at all it should be to help them
overcome that delusion not affirm it
um
nate b says just stop talking dude you
don't know what you're talking about
well you know what
nate
you make a very good point
i really i hadn't thought of it that way
but as i read this now and i look at the
argument that you presented you say and
this is fascinating you say just stop
talking dude
which is which is already profound
enough but then you also say you don't
know what you're talking about and i and
i had never
considered that
until you presented this argument like
that and now i mean frankly my whole
i can see my whole world view is sort of
crumbling right now in my head i'm
questioning everything i thought
because of that so thank you so much for
that uh really intelligent argument i
really appreciate it
um
and uh
finally
uh where is finally
here it is according to history channels
ancient aliens i and all others with
negative blood are descended from aliens
maybe that's why i'm so anxious to get
off this planet you know what i think
you're joking but ancient aliens
they're going to be the one the people
involved in ancient aliens and history
channel which has long been one of my
favorite shows which you could probably
tell
they are going to have the ultimate i
told you so moment
in the end
they're gonna be the ones
and they may be the only ones who
survive when the when the alien invasion
begins who knows
well it's time to take the mask off
which you really should have never been
wearing in the first place um but what
we're gonna do is take the mask off a
few different ways with uh the latest
backstage where we make sense of the
senseless events that have taken place
over the past month so join jeremy
boring ben shapiro michael knowles and
andrew clavin tomorrow night wednesday
may 26th for another cigar and
reason-packed episode of backstage it
streams at seven o'clock eastern 6 p.m
central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel uh daily wire
also um after a year of authoritarian
lockdowns you could probably use a
vacation i think we all could
but you might get one
best kind of vacation is a free one you
can get one maybe a free one to
nashville if you sign up as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 20 off
your new membership and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip to
the daily wire studios to see candice
live not only will you be meeting
candace you'll be getting an inside look
at her studio our office our
in front row seats to watch her live and
in action on her talk show candace so
don't wait go enter to win a candace vip
pass now at dailywire.com subscribe
using code vip for 20 off let's get now
to our daily cancellation
today with righteous rage we're going to
cancel glamour magazine glamour's
website recently featured a story with a
headline that you already know is going
to be a problem because it contains the
word empowering
it also contains the word normalize
which is even more problematic so
putting it all together the headline
declares
this empowering instagram photo to
normalize facial hair for anyone who's
grown up believing
it's uh something to be ashamed of just
went viral now the article reads
because you need to hear this very
important news
it says whether you remove yours with
waxing shaving or sugaring
sugaring what the hell is that
or embrace it in all its glory what you
do with your body hair is totally your
choice we were all born with it and it's
our right to show it off as we damn well
please which is why we have a serious
amount of time for this photo doing the
rounds on instagram
joanna j kenny a 31 year old british
esthetician took to instagram to share a
close-up snap of her upper lip hair in
all its glory
gross
upper lip hair in all its glory
alongside the most empowering caption
for all of my dark-haired friends i'm
wearing my new lipstick and blue mascara
to remind you all that facial hair is
normal she captioned the picture of
arbor lip joanna explains that she first
started noticing upper lip hair in
general facial fuzz when she was a teen
quite rightly the skin care guru
explains that like acne pores lines and
wrinkles facial hair is airbrushed from
most forms of media which she says is
most people's point of reference to
determine what is normal
so this is mean normalizing facial hair
for anyone who's grown up believing it's
something to be ashamed of she signs off
obviously she amassed plenty of
supportive comments from her followers
with people thinking thanking her for
sharing the unfiltered post
and they were then informed that this is
not the first time this woman has posted
to celebrate facial hair on women the
article says that she recently shared a
list of all the reasons why her facial
hair makes her beautiful
and it's so empowering
i'm not going to read the list because
frankly i'm too repulsed
at this point to do that we're going to
completely also leave to the side
the issue that the left really can't
normalize bearded women at this point as
they've already made it clear that
bearded women are probably men anyway i
mean they expanded gender roles until
the whole thing snapped back like a
rubber band and is now more constricted
than ever
so now we must suspect at least
according to modern logic that any woman
who wants to grow a beard
is probably actually a man trapped in a
woman's body
but as i said we'll ignore that
logistical complication for now
what about this idea
um that it's beautiful and should be
normalized for women to grow facial hair
my short answer to that is no gross stop
my longer answer is seriously disgusting
what are you doing my even longer answer
is that there's a reason why to my
knowledge
no culture has ever embraced female
facial hair as the pinnacle
of feminine beauty go back even to the
ancient egyptians and women were shaving
and removing hair by whatever primitive
means were available to them my
understanding is that they would attach
jellyfish to their faces and singe it
off
and when i say that was my understanding
i mean that i made it up but in any case
the point is
women have always removed that kind of
unsightly hair why
well there's a reason why facial hair on
men
is considered attractive while facial
hair on women is not and this is an
important point because we hear all
about the beauty standards and it's
supposed to all be arbitrary it's not
arbitrary
much of the time
so what's the difference well namely
that facial hair is largely a product of
testosterone
women are biologically inclined to
pursue men with higher levels of
testosterone
some of this biological conditioning may
be under siege in recent years as some
women these days gravitate towards more
sort of androgynous effeminate types you
know the scrawny sexless hairless
gumbies who look like voldemort if he
grew a nose and joined a boy band those
guys exist and there are women who for
whatever reason find them appealing but
for the most part even now
women whether they're conscious of it or
not will prefer men who give off signs
of virility and strength
on the other hand
men again with some notable exceptions
are not looking for the same sorts of
things in a woman if a man wanted a
woman who was like a man
he'd be gay if he isn't gay then he
wants a woman who's a woman
and on women from a man's perspective
facial hair does not signal desirable
things as it does as it does on men for
women
instead it signals
poor hygiene
and a woman who doesn't care about her
appearance and doesn't take care of her
appearance
of course a woman is free to present
that way if she wants but she can't be
offended when men are repulsed
because we're told sexual orientation
right is it's not changeable it's
immutable
so
as heterosexual men we want what we want
and uh we can't help it
and we don't want to be tickled by a
woman's mustache when we go in for the
kiss that's just that's not what we want
that's not our sexual orientation
is it possible to change all of this
i mean could you over time
condition men to find hairy unkempt
slovenly women attractive
could you condition them even to prefer
that sort of presentation
is this all a matter of arbitrary social
constructs that that can be changed
is beauty truly in the eye of the
beholder
well those are all different questions i
suppose and the answer to the lot to the
last question is no beauty is not just
in the eye of the beholder
there is an objective quality to beauty
like there are things that are
objectively beautiful and things that
are objectively ugly and if you
think that
that an objectively ugly thing is
beautiful it's not just your perspective
you're actually wrong you have you have
the wrong perspective
we hear so much about shifting beauty
standards
and it's true that superficial
preferences may change over time but the
fact is
that a woman who everyone would find
beautiful today
would be seen as beautiful probably at
any time in history anywhere in the
world
there is no time or place or culture
that would shriek in horror and
revulsion
at the site of marilyn monroe for
example
now there are some places that would
have stoned her to death but that's not
because she was ugly
so beauty is not simply a matter of
subjective preference
there is an objective quality to it
that holds across all cultures
with that said is facial hair a more
superficial matter could you condition
men to like it could you really succeed
in normalizing it in that way
i think probably not
but even if you could here's the other
question why try
there's nothing wrong with the current
standard just because a standard exists
today and has always existed
it doesn't mean in and of itself that it
should be deconstructed and
deconstructed and overturned
this is what we hear
all the time as if it's self-evident
we're told oh this is a just a social
societal standard we have to get rid of
it
well even if i agree that it's even if
theoretically
it's a basically arbitrary social
standard
why does that mean we should get rid of
it
in fact as gk chesterton warned
we should want to know why offense was
put in place before we tear it down
which means
the benefit of the doubt should go to
the historical standard unless a very
good reason can be given for getting rid
of it
and it's a hassle to wax my upper lip
is not a good reason
stop complaining
and take care of your body and your
appearance that is part of your
responsibility as a woman
yes
jess says it's the responsibility of a
man to do the same for himself women
have a right to complain when men allow
themselves to become flabby shabby weak
pudgy little things
men can likewise complain when women not
only allow themselves to be unkempt and
unfeminine and gross but even demand to
be celebrated for
all sides should do their part
this is equality
and for women part of your part is
making sure you don't look like
commissioner gordon when you go out in
public
and that is why glamour magazine and all
women attempting to normalize female
facial hair
are all today
canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by sasha tulmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nika geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. the media
blamed trump for their own cover-up of
the wuhan lab an increasing number of
women are choosing to detransition after
transgender therapy and ron desantis
takes a big swing at the liberal
establishment check it out on the
michael knowles show
[Music]